[Music]
well it's been a couple years since i
made a build video but i'm constantly
getting asked about what builds i'm
running in my lore videos
and since i have a bit of time right now
i thought i'd throw one together
to show the three main builds i use
depending on the content i'm playing
i'll be the first to admit these builds
are far from optimized
and i could certainly put some more time
into finding the perfect pieces
to get more out of them but my
priorities are a little different
and my game time is pretty stretched as
it is
however what i found is that these
somewhat average builds
using just the right amount of synergy
are more than enough to get you through
the most difficult content in the game
so let's just call these the top three
builds for the average joe
even when i was making build videos i
would never state that you need to match
every piece 100
more that this was a starting point
where you can adapt to your own style of
play
now being that i'm no build guy i'll be
running through these pretty quick
i'll be leaving the detailed build
videos up to the pros
at the end of this video i'll attach a
cheat sheet for each build that you can
take a snapshot of
and use as a quick reference guide
[Music]
the three builds are run the majority of
the time with about six or seven others
i dabble in are generally chosen based
on the content i'm about to play
it's worth noting that i'm a
predominantly solo player these will all
still work in group play but they
weren't built with that in mind
the first build i'll run you through is
probably my longest lasting build
that i put together not long after the
division 2 was released and i've changed
very little with it since then
pieces have been nerfed some have been
buffed but it still works great so i
haven't really changed much
it's reasonably fast at clearing enemies
at lower difficulties
yet strong enough to take on heroic and
legendary enemies with ease
this is also my go-to with a couple of
slight adjustments depending on the team
i'm running with for the first raid
which we all know is all about dps
it's pretty much an all-round build it's
adequate but
not particularly amazing or specialized
in any particular area
originally built for the lmg rifle combo
because my favorite archetype assault
rifles
were pretty lackluster on release but
these days it runs pretty good for both
first we have the coyotes exotic mask
for a big boost to critical hit chance
and damage
the backpack the providence defense with
vigilance
with attributes rolled into critical hit
chance and critical hit damage
in the vest slot is providence defense
with unbreakable
with attributes rolled into critical hit
chance and critical hit damage
unbreakable for the solo player helps
with survivability
in a team situation you may want to try
glass cannon for extra damage
for the gloves i'm using contractor's
petrol's defense with the spare
attribute
rolled into critical hit damage
in this slot is the cesca holster with
attributes rolled into critical hit
charts
and critical hit damage
the knee pads are fox's prayer overlord
armaments with the spare attribute
rolled into critical hit damage
[Music]
the skills are the reviver hive because
you know
solo player and the fixer drone just to
take the edge off some of the incoming
damage
this is kind of a free slot that'll
often change out depending on what i'm
coming up against
the primary weapons include the famas
with the killer talent
which is great for [ __ ] builds and the
classic m1a with rifleman
to give a bit of range plus it hits like
a truck
for the sidearm any pistol with the
finisher talent will do the job
all that critical hit damage adds up
for the specialization i'm using gunner
for the amaron kill
plus the ammo over time comes in quite
useful for some of the directives
the name pays homage to my diablo 2
roots
basically this build is good for running
through content fast
built purely around dps and life
leeching talents what
well armor leeching talents the idea is
to never stop shooting
or you'll die the gameplay style
requires you to be up front
in the thick of the action although it
can be run in heroic difficulty
it's certainly much better suited to
challenging or below
this is the sort of build that i would
use from push for time and need to run
through bounties or missions as quickly
as possible
first we have the hunter's fury mask
with all attributes rolled into critical
hit chance and critical hit damage
for the backpack we're using the memento
exotic you are up front and center
hard against the enemies so collecting
these trophies are easy to achieve
this will give increased weapon damage
armor and skill efficiency
in the vest slot the bellstone armory
with intimidate
with all attributes rolled to critical
hit chance and critical hit damage
the intimidate talent synchronizes well
with the momento backpack
providing a 35 boost to weapon damage
for the gloves hunter's fury with the
spare attribute rolled into critical hit
damage
the holster is also hunter's fury again
with attributes rolled into critical hit
damage
yet again the knee pads are hunter's
fury with the attribute rolled into
critical hit damage
the skills being used are the reviver
hive and the crusader ballistic shield
i'm generally not a fan of running
shields but given how close you need to
get to the npcs this can really help
soak up some of that damage before you
get to the point of taking down the
targets
the primary weapons include the
chatterbox exotic smg
which is great for this build you need
to be up close anyway where smgs are in
their element
plus it gets a buff from the hunter's
fury set and this talent can be used to
keep your magazine full of ammo as well
as increase your rate of fire
the other weapon is up to you if you're
using the chatterbox you probably won't
be changing over too often
here i'm using the mop shotgun for more
armor on kill
again the sidearm is up to you i use the
kdi card custom
which gives another skill tier towards
my shield
for the specialization i'm using gunner
for even more armor on kill
and the fact that the ammo slowly
replenishes helps keep you moving
forward
and reducing the need to collect ammo
in my opinion still the strongest type
of build you can make in the division 2
especially with the more recent update
adding gear that can get even
greater numbers out of your skills it
certainly isn't the most exciting way of
playing the game
having your skills do most of the damage
but don't think that this means you just
deploy
and sit back to get the most out of this
build you still need to be shooting
and a lot as i may have already implied
this build is suited to all situations
but can be a little slow so the best
place to use this
is with the most difficult content
personally i really only use this build
for legendary missions these days
which will give you the greatest chance
for completion with the least amount of
player skill required
for the mask i'm using the impress
international with attributes rolled
into skill damage
and haste the backpack is hanayu
with perfect combined arms attributes
are rolled into skill damage
and haste combined arms increases your
skill damage
after hitting an enemy with your weapon
in the vest slot we have the wyven wear
with kinetic momentum
with attributes rolled into skill damage
and haste you should be seeing a trend
here
the gloves are empress international
with attributes rolled into skill damage
and haste again
the holster is the waveform exotic this
will provide another massive buff to
your skill damage
and the knee pads are hanayu yet again
with attributes rolled into skill damage
and haste the skills being used are the
striker drone and assault turret
arguably the drone is more important
even though it does less damage
and has a tendency to get stuck in
random places all the time
the fact that it isn't stationary it
will go off and chase npcs out of hiding
which reduces the need for you to go out
into the open and given that you're
quite squishy this is definitely a bonus
the primary weapons include the
capacitor exotic assault rifle
for huge buffs to your skill damage and
it also has some fairly decent weapon
damage
and the harmony rifle for a bit of range
plus the perfectly in sync talent
provides a good boost to your skill
damage as well
for the sidearm the maxim 9 pistol is
pretty good
if for some reason you need to pull out
your sidearm this will give you the best
bang for your buck with your skills
due to the perfect spike talent
i've used the technician specialization
the extra skill tear this provides
isn't necessary but it does add another
7.5
weapon damage to the capacitor i prefer
to use it for the extra skill damage
and the bonus damage to drones and
robotics
i must admit after so long it was quite
fun putting this video together
this probably won't be useful to the
majority of you but for those of you who
keep asking what i'm running i now have
something to point you towards
as i said earlier i have a number of
other builds to run too these would just
be the main ones that i play around with
i'm currently working on a sniper build
that works more like the marksman rifle
builds we had in the division one
basically i still want to be able to
one-shot enemies but without the painful
scoping time that has been forced on us
in the division two
anyway thank you very much for watching
though it's been a while since i made
any guides or how-to videos i'm thinking
i might try and pop the odd one out
every now and then
game lore is still my thing and will
still be a priority but for during times
where there is less for me to talk about
it could be something a little different
for me to have a play around with
thanks again cheers
[Music]
okay